absolutely I mean solitaire doesn't need
to apologize for the actions of one
idiot I don't hold her responsible I
don't hold 80,000 people in March
absolutely peacefully yes a three
Manchester to express their political
views responsible the person responsible
was the person who decided to walk up to
me and spit in my face
that was his way of expressing yourself
and frankly it's not on the other people
who forced me to be quite angry with a
hundred or so people who surrounded
myself and my colleague Kate McCann from
The Telegraph I said that because we
were from the media we deserved it that
that did make me angry again that is not
representative of the 80,000 people who
marched I accept that and they don't
need to apologize I think there does
need to be perhaps a little bit of quiet
reflection from some people at the top
who don't like the way the countries run
absolutely fine don't even like the way
the media acts again absolutely fine
we'll just be careful with the rhetoric
because you fire people up when you fire
people up and they get together in large
crowds I've seen it
I'm a football sport I go to a lot of
football matches I see the way a crowd
can turn you know these things can
happen I just think it believes to calm
down a little bit as you said it wasn't
representative in many people's eyes of
the the mass crowds that were there but
being a journalist being at events like
this all the time do you think there is
a ramping up of this feeling against the
media against the press the
establishment as some people have seen I
think there is and I think that as
journalists is the press we need to look
at it and see whether they these
concerns are justified these concerns
are put to journalists and editors in a
constructive way the other thing I'll
say is Fino I'm not a political editor
you know I'm a lowly I'm a lonely hack
so sort of you know spitting in my face
is like speaking as someone who works in
Starbucks for their company's tax regime
who knows it's not productive it was
achieving it being actually I was there
yesterday to report on that March to go
out there and speak to the people get
their views reported back put it up on
Huffington Post website get people
reading it I wasn't able to do that
yesterday because of what happened so
really you know this person I'm getting
a lot of abuse on Twitter from people
what they need to be angry at this
person actually because he's the one who
stops me doing my job and reporting on
something which I imagine people on the
March
would like to have reported and reports
today as well of
journalists with their accreditation
badges walking and being verbally abused
as they go in I mean it it does still
seem that even after your case that
journalists people visiting the
conference are fair game that seems to
be the mentality and I just think you
know we live in a wonderful country
where we have a wonderful free press and
the best thing about the press in this
gun so we don't like it you can turn the
channel over you could turn the radio if
you think it to buy the paper you don't
lie you don't need to go to the website
that winds you up so much so I don't
understand where a lot of this victory
all comes from because you don't want to
engage in this in the outlets you don't
like you don't have to it's not forced
upon you so I think that directing it a
journalist it's victory oh I just think
it's so counterproductive in it you know
all the 80,000 people in March let's say
peacefully to raise their concerns over
what's happened to them what the
government's doing you know they're
their voice which is lost yesterday
because it's been overshadowed by a few
instances but actually this is the
beginning of something and it doesn't we
flagged up it interesting is that I mean
there's been various talk will Jeremy
Coleman come and March with the
anti-austerity March as mean he has
marched in in the past and you do see
marches at the other conferences but on
a much smaller scale I mean it's a very
direct left versus right what's
happening there in Manchester at the
moment isn't it yes and I think that
although this is not she was certainly
not caused by Jeremy but I think now
using the Labour Party just move to the
left there is that she's our first clear
blue water now between the Tories and
labour so I think a lot of people on the
far left a hard left
perhaps flocking to the cause of the
Labour Party they weren't before
alongside you know your moderate labor
voters was always about the party
through thick and thin they're coming
together and forming a big group on the
Left you know that's fine that's
perfectly fine for them to protest it's
a democratic right and I'll absolutely
always always support that but I think
within that you need to sort of set out
the terms of engagement here and say you
know we're gonna protest we're gonna
make noise we're gonna keep going on
about our case but when what we're not
going to do is intimidate we're not
going to harass we're not going to
attack and that needs to come from the
very very top so if Charlotte Church
does want to write anything on top
saying she asked e-cigarettes nickel on
those words they're not me absolutely
fantastic if she could do it then you
know more power to you Charlotte I can
see her taking notes as you speak so
when you editor
next says to Owen its conference season
do do well actually maybe not this time
it put you off not at all and tonight
I'm actually going down to the Jeremy
Corbyn rally that's being held here in
Manchester I'm gonna go down I'm gonna
report on that I'm going to take notes
I'm gonna do what I do every day in my
job I'm not gonna be intimidated by
these people because I know that
yesterday in the midst of all that all
the carnage and the police having to
sort of hide me and my collar to get
into a hotel lobby there was people
there it was saying leave them alone
they're from the press even if they
weren't from the press leave them alone
it's just not the way we should be
conducting politics in this country so
certainly not going to stop me doing my
job